le prix record du bois d'oeuvre était le
sujet de l'art au début de l'été c'était
difficile pour tout le monde chez pour
les entrepreneurs pour les constructeurs
c'est un succès pour les clients aussi
sachez que le prix de certains matériaux
atterri pelé hall pays 1200 une semaine
deux semaines après en termes il doit
aussi deux autres semaines après elle
paye 1400 au bout du compte ce sont les
acheteurs devront payer la facture la
blague n'a rien d'étonnant dans le jeu
nous sinon à penske à 91 dollars
les fabricants de bois d'oeuvre ont
engrangé des profits monstre grâce à une
demande sans précédent durant la
pandémie mais ce qui leur fournissent en
partie la matière première les
producteurs de forêts privées n'ont pas
vu la couleur de cet argent au moins je
vois ça comme un manque de respect de la
part de l'industrie de pas vouloir nous
faire profiter de ce qu'ils reçoivent le
ministère des forêts a encaissé beaucoup
plus de redevances sur le bois vendus
aux compagnies forestières mais le prix
exorbitant des matériaux a révolté les
québécois est plombé leur portefeuille
sans dire qu'il va y avoir des immeubles
je pense qu'il ya un sentiment que chez
les citoyens québécois le québec est
riche de forêt mais qui ajuste certains
groupes la société qui en bénéficient
avec les consommateurs et les
producteurs du côté des perdants et les
tailles industrie forêt servent dans le
camp des gagnants la situation devient
intenable quand les billots de bois se
transforme en billets de banque
le bas saint laurent est reconnu pour
ses paysages au bord du fleuve mais
aussi pour ses forêts privées qui
ressemblent à des jardins
chez lez beaulieu la forêt tient une
place importante autour de la table ce
sont des bûcherons du 21ème siècle qui
vendent leurs arbres ou syrie pour faire
du bois d'oeuvre on cultive le forez de
nos enjeux
de notre faim parce que
aussi pour une prochaine génération
bien enracinée sur la terre de ses
ancêtres à biencourt janot beaulieu à
retendre six mille deux cents hectares
de forêt si c'est là les terres de mon
grand pas et
ça ça a été planté en 1965
dans la dernière année et demie alors
que plusieurs s'imaginait que les
producteurs s'en mettaient plein les
poches sa colère a grimpé aussi vite que
le prix du bois sur le marché on le sait
qu'après calvin klein qu'on va le
chercher a gagné six rangs juste prix
lol c'est parce que quelqu'un devait pas
au terme de profiter et c'est pour vous
c'est bonjour en fait les séries ont
empoché jusqu'à 300 % de plus pour leurs
produits finis le prix du bois est
revenue à la normale mais monsieur
beaulieu n'oubliera jamais qu'il n'a
obtenu que 15 % d'augmentation
après des mois d'attentes le partage
équitable de la richesse le moteur pour
moi c'est important puis moi je trouve
ça comme épouvantable c'est un profit
exceptionnel
pour le fabrique un le manufacturier de
boer le professeur luc bouthilier assure
que la frustration des trente mille
producteurs privés qui vendent du bois
au québec est légitime quand les prix
sont très bons pour les produits le
producteur de bois lui dans le système
actuel il n'ya pas sa part son le
montrer de façon éclatante pendant des
mois
l'industrie a transformé presque
littéralement des piles de bois empile
d'argent des millions de dollars de
profits chaque jour au bas-saint-laurent
celui qui a gagné le gros lot c'est le
groupe lebel
d'excellentes ventes lé ce côté canadien
québec un mari de samy et ontario ce
soir c'est une année record pour nous ce
fabricant de matériaux comme le reste de
l'industrie a enfin pu renflouer ses
coffres après la crise forestière des
dernières années
la guerre du bois d'oeuvre entre le
canada et les états unis conjuguées aux
crises économiques qui ont frappé
l'amérique du nord avait alors provoqué
une baisse radicale du prix des
matériaux qui a heurté toute l'industrie
forestière
les séquelles sont sont derrière nous le
remise à zéro le pdg a entendu la grogne
des québécois provoqué par les coups du
bois mais il refuse d'endosser le rôle
du méchant pour la première fois dans
les xe est important le plus du parc est
par contre qu'un quant aux produits
visite du parc est à perte leur entre
2008 et 2015 2500 personnes qui veulent
nous porter un bois dans une valise
d'argent mais pas pour m'encourager
la famille beaulieu n'a pas non plus
reçu de valises d'argent mais elle
traîne encore le poids de la crise elles
mois baissé de 40% dans crise forestière
ok c'est 40 pour ça on ne jamais appris
en fait la flambée des prix à amplifier
un sentiment partagé par des producteurs
partout au québec ils se sentent floués
dans le village voisin à auclair jean
marie gilbert dénoncent une injustice
qui selon lui perdure depuis trop
longtemps il doit vendre ces arbres
arabe et son prêt avec l'indexation du
coût de la vie on a moins d'argent
aujourd'hui dans la vente de bois qu'on
avait bloqué est ailleurs et dans sa
région l'exaspération est à son comble à
cause du quasi-monopole du groupe lebel
une situation tabou dont presque
personne ne veut parler en raison de
l'importance de l'industrie forestière
avant on avait plusieurs acheteurs
potentiels et 20 de certaines
compétitions entre les acheteurs qui
faisait qu'on nous allons point de
négocier de prix un peu plus
qu'actuellement on çà démunis dans un
scénario comme cela on nous dit c'est
sûr ils optent accès ce monopole le
groupe lebel a racheté les petites
scieries menacée de fermeture au bas
saint laurent ça a permis de sauver les
emplois et les usines l'envers de la
médaille c'est une concentration du
pouvoir d'achat pour les
les producteurs il ya moins d'acheteurs
à la clé moins d'acheteurs mais autant
douzaine donc
[Musique]
les syndicats de producteurs forestiers
sont catégoriques c'est dans cette
région où 50 % de la forêt privée que
les prix payés pour leurs bois est le
plus bas au québec sont une région de sa
fin sapin c'est pas une essence prisés
une naissance qui est peu coûteuse de
france formée moi je pensais que c'était
un peu la raison pourquoi les
producteurs réussi dans vos salaires en
pense qu'ils ont passés chapeau aux
produits quoi qu'il en soit des
producteurs comme jeannot beaulieu ne
vendent pas leurs bois aux scieries du
groupe lebel situé à côté de chez eux il
envoie à 230 km dans une usine
concurrente de chaudière appalaches qui
paie 1500 $ de plus par camion en
soustrayant 1000 $ de frais de transport
il gagne encore 500 dollars de plus
qu'au bas saint laurent le groupe lebel
est au courant il possède aussi des
scieries dans chaudière appalaches et y
offrent un meilleur prix ces jeunes sont
ils trop modernes sont plus proches des
marchés donc ça explique un peu pourquoi
on fait une chaîne
il promet d'ailleurs que la cagnotte de
la dernière année servira à moderniser
son parc de vieilles séries du
bas-saint-laurent et que ça profitera
aux producteurs
pour jeannot beaulieu la solution c'est
de négocier un prix provincial du bois
avec l'industrie comme le font les
producteurs de lait ou de sirop d'érable
négociales les grilles avec l'industrie
ben alors apprécié on sait que le prix
qu on le négocie ingres et juste autant
pour l'industrie plongeon et il a
l'appui de cet homme le président de la
fédération des producteurs forestiers du
québec le vide et c'est que si le prix
du bois tombe tout le monde partage la
baisse et s'il monte tout le monde
partage aussi la hausse
les appels du monde qui nous y fier
parce que tu as raison on doit aller
plus loin de s'organiser la sapo c'est
un scandale qu'on ne lui lol on devra
avoir pour ce que les petits plus fort
pour négocier par faire plus d'efforts
pour négocier nous ta cote et respect
c'est un combat de david contre goliath
et non goliath ce n'est pas que
l'industrie c'est aussi l'état québécois
qui le plus grand vendeur de boiron de
la province
comme propriétaire des forêts publiques
le gouvernement produit 80% des bio au
québec et il décide du prix payé par
l'industrie contrairement aux
producteurs privés et son prix est
indexé à celui du marché entre janvier
2005 et juin 2021 ces redevances ont
donc grimpé de 140%
notre plus gros compétiteur la forêt
privée c'est la forêt publique et ce
compétiteur le ministère des forêts qui
subventionne l'industrie à coups de
dizaines de millions de dollars chaque
année pour protéger des emplois a
enregistré des déficit récurrente dans
le passé suggère m à forer un site comme
cela n'existerait plus ça fait longtemps
c'est pas normal que dans un contexte où
le ministère ne sont pas une seule avec
le bourg la forêt publique que l'estrie
devient
milliardaire de cette compétition
déloyale parce qu'à l'intérieur de la
loi
sur les forêts et you le principe de
résidualité ce principe là résidualité
veut dire que l'industrie devrait faire
le plein en forêt privée avant d'aller
piger dans nos forêts publiques mais ce
ne serait pas toujours respectée selon
le ministère une fois les scénarios
d'approvisionnement établi pour les
usines la loi n'oblige pas les
industriels à acheter les bois provenant
des forêts privées à la hauteur de ce
qui était prévu c'est un système qui a
été conçu il ya 35 ans alors il est
temps de l'actualiser soeur faut revoir
le système de façon à ce que le
propriétaire privé qui met des arbres
marché pour permettre la transformation
et sa part le gouvernement répond qu'il
n'intervient pas dans les prix payés aux
producteurs de forêt privée puisqu'il
s'agit de libre marché or l'indignation
suscitée par le prix du bois d'oeuvre a
alimenté la méfiance du public luc
bouthilier crois qu'il faut des
changements rapides si on ne fait pas ce
passage ben la population qu'ils aient
l'impression d'être floués
ce qu'elles vont exiger c'est qu'on
sorte l'industrie de la forêt
[Musique]
pour qu'une cinquième génération puisse
elle aussi cultiver la forêt familiale
et bien en vivre jeannot beaulieu promet
de continuer le combat ce pont un
héritage qu'on veut laisser à nos
enfants sont
l'héritage de d'avoir l'impression qu'on
se fait exploiter
[Musique]
en